I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning Anne but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
[Music]
Natalie's parents believe that she is
being possessed by some sort of evil
entity
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
foreign
student in the class only as an observer
because as you know women are strictly
forbidden from performing exorcism
female surgeons are once Unthinkable
somebody had to be the first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lured into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
I can't hear you no
[Music]
apparently I'm here
you have a gift I'd like to teach her
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
love is God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you